what do you mean what do you mean
[Music]
like this
you got here
maybe that is you are infected
it must have happened during the last
testing cycle the protocol should have
been enough to prevent
[Music]
conditions hold on a second hello
everybody my name is Markiplier and I'm
finally back in my office recording
again and I'm playing a game that I've
heard very much about while I was over
filming iron lung mostly from the
developer of iron lung himself David
Smith I don't think I've actually
pronounced his last name out loud
but anyway this is dread XP collection
2. I've been meaning to play these a lot
and I think I might have actually tried
to make a video where I did make a video
about one of them in the past I don't
really remember anymore
push hush hush hush hush for now I will
get to you in just a second also
subtitles should be honest it's there if
you want to read it that's the story
that's going to be there
there's a key on top that's a key
you trying to tell me that's a key oh
it opens anyway it looks like the voices
done in this collection is a game that
I've been hearing non-stop as being the
game with the best ending that David has
ever made and no it's not Sucker For
Love which I was surprised to find is in
this collection before it came out as
its own game it is
squirrel stapler I've heard a lot a lot
a lot
your legs still work uh all good Signs
Now for the harder part
we're going to have to give you a
cognitive kick that should be enough to
jump start your your natural neural
defense mechanisms in normal
circumstances we'd be able to just
recontextualize your Inlet traumas in
every
full coverage through neural and
planting but that's
that's an option anymore
so I well improvised
see those VHS tapes blocked
locked up yes use that key to open up
one but then just pop that bad boy into
the VCR and uh
okay I can't really
okay so this is actually a game
collection that I've been meaning to
play for a very long time if for some
reason I have not and I don't know why I
have not there's no reason why I have
not it's great for three scary games
because it's nothing but game
collections in a game collection games
in a game collection not game collection
and a game collection that doesn't make
any sense but this one I'm going to
start with and it's going to be its own
Standalone thing to get me back into the
mode of recording
squirrel stapler interactive small game
hunting now I know what you're thinking
what kind of game is this well
apparently it's so profoundly
life-changing that nothing is going to
look the same after I'm done with it so
I'm gonna play it and that's the end of
it yes use key
hello
unlocked tape and comic page press
inventory to view
it really
[Music]
really [__] done this was the last
time
I drove four hours to Flagstaff
holistic as much as far as plans to go
but at least I was certain of it I could
just keep my engine running in the wheel
straight that's all there was to it
would it turn around not this time
after that I figure it out
God my grave nothing would get me to go
back
not this time
not even the sky falling down
so remember I said this with dredx
collection number two there's probably
some other story that is following
through here and I'm jumping out of
order but I have scroll stapler and
that's all that matters to me so I'm
gonna go staple some squirrels
yes please
I'm not exaggerating
when I say that this game is not what it
seems apparent
ah
scroll Stabler time to staple some
squirrels
hello
oh
we came here to get away from it all so
that our love might Blossom but our love
is not blossomed look at my beloved the
flies have made her ugly and rotten
I wish you were beautiful like the
squirrels of the wood
so I will cover her in the squirrels of
the wood
um the poop so my poop bucket
okay
see I thought
I thought that the crazy might be hidden
beneath a few layers of Dead Squirrels
but turns out it's all right on a
surface is that a demonic summoning
Circle
oh save the god of the wood Thou shalt
not staple squirrels what was it Goat no
goats don't know anything why am I gonna
trust a weird floating note over a demon
summoning symbol over what I know in my
own heart and what my wife needs my wife
needs stapled squirrels
well this is the saddest kitchen I've
ever seen
hmm
in five days God is coming
well I don't know if I wrote this
message or if this is a message from
some kind of Herald oh
what is that it is time to hunt the
squirrels
well that was easy
I was already dead
not really much of a game if you're just
gonna offer it nothing like that use the
map to orient yourself
um
just like iron lung
I see interesting
running's loud and can scare squirrels
away before you even see them walk
whenever possible stay low to hide in
the foliage and creep quietly you're
practically undetectable if you hide in
the weeds use your ears you can usually
hear squirrels chattering and moving
before you can see them your rifle is
equipped with a scope use it to bag
varmints at long range
okie dokie then
so keep your ears peeled for some
chattering
uh-huh oh
no it's just a log
anybody seen any squirrels
nope what is that
bullets
they'll mind if I do
never mind I don't
hello
squirrel
I heard that
oh you scampering aren't you
oh you're scrambling
oh don't worry
I'm sure that you also will die of
completely natural causes just like the
squirrel outside of my own home
naturally you'd die if you had a giant
bullet wound
where you at squirrel
oh do I not need those
oh I have a sound bar interesting
I hear you
where are you
usually squirrels are in trees right or
are they going to be on the ground
what is that
no you can't what no I'm crouched
I'm so crouched
how did you see me
oh that was you
don't you worry
don't you worry your pretty little Pelt
you're going to make my wife
can I hit something from that far away
trying
oh no
interesting
either there's some bullet physics or
I'm not 100 sure with what's going on
there
squirrel oops
did I get it hot damn I got myself a
squirrel
so I guess the icon has to say squirrel
huh
squirrel oh
oh yeah you too
let me go get this squirrel carcass
before it gets to
unbeautiful
for my wife wow you don't look so good
well I mean you're dead I don't know
well I mean I guess I'm trying to make
my wife look good so you better look
some kind of good
I'm caught in a dichotomy
yay why are they so squishy I don't like
how squishy they are they have no need
to be that squishy
okay I have cocked
my gun is cocked
is that it
that is it yeah that's it right there
oh come on
I gotta get this one Kirks
mine
no yes all right
okay so this isn't as bad as I thought
it was you go out and get some squirrels
and you staple them to your wife
assuming all right that's enough
squirrels for today they need to
repopulate before
be beautiful again
okey-dokey then
buy squirrels poison grass do not eat
ah you lucky up well never mind you're
not lucky can I have another
oh it doesn't even count
alive
my sweet my love how are you
oh
oh there you are press action default
left Mouse to staple the squirrels to my
beloved
yay
all right
babe
you never look more beautiful
[Music]
ah okay yeah I I am
is this like I'm in a coma thing and
you're trying to tell me that I need to
wake up oh
oh baby you looking as beautiful as ever
maybe even more
did you gain five squirrels I'll go get
you some more well I'm sure that this
demonic thing cannot come back to haunt
me ah no more notes from goats
that's good to know
I never needed it in the first place in
five days God is coming well I think
it's four days so you might want to
update your message
yes yay to midday I must hunt the big
what
oh call
[Music]
hey
how do I know when there's a big
squirrel
damn I'm good at that
come here
bear squirrels
squirrel
no
okay then
yeah there's something in the Far Far
corner it seems
yes please
squirrel
whoa is that a
is that is that is that a squirrel ghost
oh
what
happened
did the squirrel Soul just make its way
into my corporeal form
oh good siren Ed's gonna be a part of
this
good squirrel
that never works
all right well that was your first
mistake what is that
I don't know what that is
where you at are you in the valley that
would be a terrible mistake
just terrible and you're not in the
valley where are you
you're over Yonder
anyone expects Slenderman music just to
start up randomly
whoa that's a big squirrel oh still goes
down with one bullet shouldn't have been
squonking big squirrel
that was your fault not mine
because you're full enough to fall for
my bills it tones doesn't mean that I
need to mourn your loss
thank you I am very strong
whoa where
if this Forest is kind of big
kind of vastly bigger than I thought it
would be
also I don't like the decomposing
Woodlands
also I'm not a big fan of the fact that
there seemed to be landmarks
I guess it's for orientation if nothing
else
maybe this is the pre-flooded version of
iron lungs Moon
is that a squirrel no it's just bullets
probably what is this about oh
oh it's a bad Circle
why ah but why though
but why
squirrels
squirrel man there were so many of them
before
now they want nothing to do with me
wait a minute that's not an ammo what is
that
that's ammo and life
everywhere I did
oh well oh a page interesting
why would there be a document
squirrels cannot burp vomit or
experience heartburn
thank you for the squirrel fact
maybe the call is only worth it for the
big squirrel maybe I do have to be more
stealthy for the other squirrels
oh yeah
so maybe I do you just have to be nice
and stealthy
that or they only spawn back closer to
my house because they don't want to be
in the deadlands
[Music]
oh
is that a square way over there I think
it is
yeah
I see you're just protected by the
foliage
oh
[Music]
all right that's all I need is that a
squirrel ghost
let me have my prize don't do anything
to me
I See You Squirrel ghost
what does that say
vengeful ghost squirrel I see do bullets
kill you two
because I got enough squirrels for one
day you don't need to bother me don't
haunt my soul
just need to get back home oh well don't
worry about it
I've had my fill of squirrel in my
beautiful wife can only tolerate so much
change in one day
really not good with change
it's been very much the same for
quite a while now
because she's dead
hello penis
all right so I go back in I staple some
more squirrels and then I live out my
life even happier than the day before
honey
you're not gonna
I see something in the doorway there
I thought I did Lexi and do a quick
playback for me
but if there isn't something there make
something there so that people don't
know if they go back and look they're
not going to think something's there but
then I'll tell them later on that if
they see something there then they're
that then there actually is something
there and there wasn't something there
before hello
I don't want squirrels I want skin give
me back my skin or give me yours instead
honey don't be ridiculous you love
squirrels have some squirrels there's a
slim kind of analogy where you don't
listen to your significant other uh
squirrel squirrel squirrel squirrel
squirrel that is just delightful it's
kind of a cool one-armed asymmetrical
thing going on
anyway love you
you think there was
close enough because there definitely
wasn't
definitely wasn't
um
okay I don't know why I keep looking as
if something's gonna change because if
something does change I'm not gonna like
that outcome
hey
something was scratching on the Windows
last night I should look for tracks
should I
you think it was a squirrel
well they're dead squirrels
oh these are not normal squirrel tracks
I something out there is hunting me well
it's not doing a very good job because
it had me dead to rights and it didn't
get me so what am I supposed to be
happy about that
be fearful rifle noise travels far and
can attract large predators
come back tomorrow for another tip
right of course
all right I just gotta be nice and
careful
squirrel
s right
all over the place
but I want a squirrel fact
squirrels use chemosensory leg and feet
hairs to identify food then track it
with their front antenna I don't believe
that
that sounds like made up nonsense
sounds like a bunch of ridiculousness
you're expecting me to believe something
like that oh
oh
what are you doing squirrel
what are you doing
what
oh that was close okay
well hey well hey
[Applause]
oh my God
okay oh I reloaded
can't forget that body over there but I
know there's a few right here
oh
all right I'm gonna go get these bodies
before I lose track of them get more
bullets at the same time before
something comes and eats me whatever the
big tracks were couldn't possibly be the
giant squirrel
and I'm not trusting any more notes
because obviously they're all made up
because that can't possibly be true
whatever the hell that was talking about
all right what
that's a bear that's a squirrel bear
does that count as an extra large
you know squirrel
don't know how I could have lost that
word
get you
imma get you
oh yeah you're mine
oh right in the dome
all right just need me a big squirrel
wait I thought I
oh I didn't pick up the other body was
that another one
no it's just another note
I don't want squirrel facts
squirrels have urine release valves
under their eyes and urinate on each
other's faces to communicate again
this doesn't seem
seems like nonsense I'm guessing the
squirrel bear must be what I'm must be
the big school
can I not get up here
why must David not want me to have fun
uh there we go I'll see squirrels for
miles oh there you are mine
where are you
all right wear me a big squirrel
oh
oh oh oh
God oh God oh God
wow I need help
goodness gracious
why did he explode
okay I need to get a big one
and be sure to cut this down into a nice
bite-sized chunk there's a lot of
unnecessaries unless I'm hilarious and
then leave it in of course but not this
don't leave this in whatever you do
don't leave this in now am I being
serious about that or is that another
multi-layered joke that I'm going for
because if you leave it in and
embarrasses me in a way that people are
like oh there's some behind the scenes
stuff going on he's trying to self-edit
as he's doing it what a Ridiculousness
unless it's impressive and even though
there is a squirrel bear that's trying
to barrel down my throat
oh
wait what do I do what do I do Elixir
what do you do what do you do in this
moment what do you do with this
predicament don't make the wrong choice
oh boy
anyway so what do I do if that happens
do I just run as quickly as possible oh
good more squirrel facts
squirrels break down their food with a
structure called gastric Mill which is
located in their stomach that one sounds
like it might be more true but I still
don't believe it
because why should I why should I
believe that what is this
there's something in the woods here that
we didn't expect I keep finding tracks
and I hear it at night moving through
the foliage and scratching on the
concrete and in the morning there are
squirrels outside the door with their
limbs all pulled off and their heads
twisted around dozens of them requesting
call for instructions on how to proceed
come back to Marvel oh crap I've been
missing reports
oh that's why it's important to come all
the way over here well I didn't know
that God I hope that isn't pertinent for
some kind of an uh true ending
because that'll be embarrassing
all right blast me
feel free maybe this could oh this could
kill the squirrel bears
maybe if it walks through there it might
blow them up before they get to me
could that be the big story
oh yeah I think that might be the big
squirrel
no that's just a normal one
sounds really Stompy
guessing it's
oh yeah punk
got him all right
honey
I'm on the way back
don't you worry about a thing huh I have
all the squirrels you've ever wanted and
more
hmm squirrels can regenerate lost limbs
although it can take a few years to do
so I
again I don't think so but I don't know
so so I can't say so whether that's true
I don't know
I've known more about squirrels in the
past few minutes than I ever wanted to
know in my entire life
honey
babe
I may have missed if
but but babe
[Music]
you've hardly touched your
plate
you hardly touched it
girl
wait a minute
oh I see
well
you know how it'd be
all right sleeping I'm sleeping
babe you're did you sleep yeah hi
I hear you loud and clear babe getting
you more squirrel
dude
so I have to make my way all the way
across to get more reports even though I
haven't gotten enough rewards
if you're being attacked you Circle
strafe tactics and Dodge around
obstacles okay
so I just gotta Quake It Up is what
you're saying
gosh
there's no way that David is a fan of
those types of games or should I say
dust it up squirrel are always watching
always
well so long as it's nothing new
squirrels can debone a human male in
under three hours well that's not very
impressive I could debone a squirrel in
under three minutes
what was it
I hear you
Wham
thank you oh
oh
boy
oh wow
well I need more bullets
[Music]
squirrels Delight in causing pain well
good then I don't feel as bad for
stapling them to my dead wife
dead wife question mark my dead wife
I know that I'm probably not doing it
right by running but I just want to get
to the other message first
and then I can make my way back slowly
because I gotta come down here no matter
what
three
two one message it's in the walls now in
the concrete looking for my brain can't
find it because my brain is inside my
skull but it will it will peel away skin
and bone to get inside when my brain is
taken I'll come for you I will break you
open I'll take yours instead I'm in the
shadows now
seeing you cower you're already
stretched apart in the pieces your head
is already Twisted off the spine
come back tomorrow for another report
all right good
I see your tail
don't think you can hide oh unless
that's just a note floating in the I
thought that was a squirrel hello
squirrel
whoa oh
don't mind me well oh god really oh
frick oh frack
hey
oh God that was Miss
oh please don't please don't nah Circle
straight
whoa
okay that's marginally effective ah so
it needs to charge in a straight line
that's weird
okay
wife wife wife
damn it oh God that's gonna kill me if
you get me
well I have to do all that again
ow
oh boy wait a minute that's not good
wait wait
I might have gotten away with it
oh maybe not oh boy okay well this is a
problem I don't have enough health for
you because I just
oh well staying hidden is a bit of an
impossibility
oh wow I've never gone in high here
either
the lady part 4 the artist lifted the ax
tears streaming
hi why
brought it down again separating her
skull into two parts and somehow still
she screamed again the ax came down and
again again
my wife well I guess I wasn't getting
any of the secrets I was so focused on
the squirrel stapling that I barely
noticed all of the story
foreign
oh this is unpleasant
I'm uncertain what's happening whoa
that's a double ungood uh two at once is
unfair
don't you all to know that oh really God
all right please let me heal before you
do that again and where did that oh
really oh you are kidding me
did I not hit that
oh God
whoa all right okay so I need health and
Amro
oh God
well at least I have Amro where did that
body go
where did that Supple squirrel body go
it's perfect for my wife wife wife wife
wife wife wife are you there why
don't be shy
it's me
you're
a pookie bear
look
I'll use some health
that's good
[Music]
I know the main problem is that I'm
running everywhere
hey
there you are
so the big one definitely is calls from
additional wow oh God
oh
thank you big squirrel and now I just
wish I knew where the other squirrel
went
where did the other squirrel go
also what am I doing with the big
squirrel I'm not stapling it to my wife
okay I'll come back for you
also where am I oh
I don't think I've been to this corner
weird
oh
[Music]
well
I am exploring
no
shouldn't have attacked me by some ammo
jokes on you remember God damn it yes I
am
so I don't know if they despawn when
they run but they would be warned
oh
what are you doing there
right now I just gotta make it back in
one piece
yeah
there's enough squirrels for today I I'm
a home
wow well that was convenient
all right good hope I don't read any
more horrible messages
can't wait to get home to my wife
girls are always watching oh that's a
squirrel fact I already knew
that's silly that's silly I knew that
life
wife
who wife
oh wife hi you're gonna love this don't
don't don't oh
perfect
I'm sleeping yep
wife how are you wife Good Good Wife
who will
offer God is coming today
okay all right good luck
I don't know about that one
[Music]
there are more squirrels and you have
bullets and you have made him very very
angry
squirrel God
the god of these squirrels you'll find
that I'm not very afraid of the God of
this squirrel
unless I should be and then I will be
but until that point is proven I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna do anything
oh
I'm not sure if the squirrel call only
works on the big squirrel because it
seems like the big squirrel's the only
one that really responds
and it responds eagerly
maybe that is true
response it would make sense it's the
only one that's consistently worked so
uh maybe I'm just an idiot
probably
hello
the artist's ears rang as he turned to
the old woman and said what is this
unspeakable horror that you have brought
to me how can I ever escape what has
been done here what penny spell can you
cast a conjugate good from this and the
old women examined the bloody mess and
said well young man this will make a
mighty fine stew and so they made a stew
from The Remains but it was poison and
they both died art will eventually
destroy the artist the end wife get a
load of this one
ain't that something
it's right there I'm
done
oh big squirrel eh
now that I've only I've learned the
secrets on day five
it's only taking me so long
oh yeah big squirrel damn it's a shame
I'm getting really good at hunting
squirrels but way way late
oh
oh there was one over there
well that would have been nice all right
[Music]
please disregard previous reports
everything is quiet well I don't know if
I believe that
I don't know if I believe any of that
I believe that all of that is a lie I
believe it's facetious I believe that
it's just patently untrue
I've known just a distinct lack of
squirrel bears
foreign
last squirrel
there you are
was wondering
God is I must prepare to what
do you mean
what do you mean by that uh I thought I
Was preparing plenty I uh I didn't know
that it was so urgent I uh I would have
been on my better best behavior
if I'd have known that this was the
thing
wife wife why am I so far why did I take
the long road back oh god oh wife man I
was much farther than I thought
why this this could be a problem
this this could be a conundrum this this
oh oh boy
oh yeah
wait wait what do you mean what do you
mean
what do you mean
what what do you mean what do you mean
[Music]
what do you mean
this is
what in the hell is happening
what I don't even know
what do you mean
[Music]
wow
what what what happened well
that was squirrel stapler I don't really
know
what happened but I hunted some
squirrels and that was made by the same
guy that made iron lung and apparently
God is here uh so thank you everybody
for watching if you haven't checked out
the iron lung teaser trail go check it
out right now on my Channel or Linked In
the description or in the suggested
video right here
if you don't
foreign